an Australian newspaper claims to have
an intelligence dossier from what's
known as the five eyes the US and its
European allies Joint Intelligence
Sharing Group now the document
reportedly lays out the extent to which
China's government covered up this true
nature and extent of the corona virus
outbreak from its earliest days in Wuhan
this is a story that Fox News was first
to break two weeks ago joining us as the
president and CEO of the Center for
Security Policy he's also a former White
House national security council chief of
staff in the Trump administration Fred
flight's Fred thanks so much for your
time today I want to ask you first up
about this this dossier it doesn't
contain anything from what we can tell
that's new that goes beyond what Fox
News has reported about what China knew
and when but it is if verified and
important confirmation that other
countries in the international community
the US has key allies agree with us in
terms of an assessment of what the
Chinese government knew and when that's
right Julian this is a joint
intelligence assessment by five Western
nations that closely cooperate on
intelligence the US UK Canada Australia
and New Zealand and you're right there's
nothing new in it but what's significant
here is that it helps us make the point
that accusations that China is guilty of
very serious misconduct possibly
criminal negligence and handling this
virus this is not congressional
Republicans and President Trump saying
that there is growing international
consensus not just that China mishandled
us but of serious Chinese wrongdoing of
the government retaliate against
scientists and doctors who try to warn
about the seriousness of this virus in
in December of 2019 of destroying
samples of lying about human to human
transition and most important and this
is made in in this document that
although the Chinese government shut
down
Wuhan in January 2020 to stop the virus
from spreading across China it did not
cut off international air flights which
allowed this virus to seed itself around
the world
and I think this is going to have a
devastating effect on China's global
reputation yeah and we now know that as
a result of failing to shut down
international travel during the earliest
weeks of the outbreak tens of thousands
of potentially infected Chinese citizens
from Wuhan traveled to other nations
around the world including the United
States and Europe Fred what do you think
now when we look forward here what do
you think is the best way for president
Trump's national security team to hold
the Chinese government accountable is
there a way to really do that well the
president does not want to destroy
relations with China he would like to
keep good relations and to protect the
gains he's made in trade talks but the
evidence has become so overwhelming
misconduct by the Chinese government
the NSC right now is considering whether
maybe we should push for reparations
whether we should let state and and
cities sue China remove sovereign
immunity limitations that would prevent
that I think we need to use this
pressure to get China to cooperate in an
international investigation of what
happened at the virology labs of Wuhan
what happened at the wet markets and
agree to some type of international
supervision of dangerous biological
research Fred in five seconds or less
can you tell us if you agree with the
president's decision to cut off funding
temporarily from the World Health
Organization I think it was the right
move and it's having an effect the World
Health Organization is now asking for an
international investigation of what
happened to one side of China which
refused to cooperate with yeah well we
got to leave it there but Fred flights
from the center for security policy
thanks so much could be here